Valentinstag steht vor der Tür deswegen
gibt's heute ein richtig herzliches
Rezept ich mache das jetzt hier mit
einem leckeren Schokoladenboden darüber
eine Creme und dann werden wir die Torte
noch richtig schön dekorieren
mal oh mein Gott die ist richtig gut die
ist so
locker hallo herzlich willkommen in
sallyis Welt heute gibt's eine leckere
Torte die nicht gebacken wird no bake
nämlich und falls ihr diese Herzform
habt könnt ihr sie darin zubereiten ihr
könnt aber auch mit diesem Rezept eine
Runde Torte zubereiten das ganze geht
ziemlich fix und es schmeckt super
lecker ich zeig euch mal kurz die drei
Zutaten die wir für den Boden benötigen
ach wisst ihr was ich ma noch eine Zutat
dazu ein Moment Tonka passt ganz gut wir
nehmen dafür 340 g Butterkekse 160 g
Butter 80 g zahbitterkvertüre und
tonkerpaste die Kekse werden jetzt
einfach kurz zerkleinert entweder macht
ihr das mit einem Mixer oder mit dem
wacker oder mit den Händen oder mit
einem streuselmaker also dieser
teigzerstampfer geht beides dann kann
ich kurz die Butter schmelzen im Topf
mache ich das kurz bei niedriger Stufe
mach dann den Herd aus und kann die
Schokolade in der Restwärme schmelzen
ich will eine Katzen katzenparty mit
Katzenohren Muffin wird drei dieses Jahr
und ich möchte auf jeden Fall könnt ihr
bitte diese komische Stimme wegschneiden
und ich möchte auf jeden Fall
katzenmotivtorte stim auch nicht
besser warte ich bleib erwachsen Muffin
wird dieses Jahr 3 Jahre alt ein kleines
Baby und ich möchte auf jeden Fall eine
katzenmotivtorte machen eine katzenparty
schmeißen Samira Ella alle die meine
Muffin lieben kriegen dann so ein
katzenhaarreif
katzenluftballocks wollt ihr auch eine
katzenmotivtorte sehen
sagt ja
bitte die Butter mit Schokolade ist
geschmolzen jetzt können wir hier die
schokobutter Tonka und die Keksbrösel
miteinander
[Musik]
kombinieren und dann kommt die Masse
jetzt hier in die Herzform rein ich habe
jetzt einfach so ein Aluminiumblech
drunter das passt nämlich super in den
Kühlschrank eine Dauerbackfolie dann
verrutscht das Ganze auch nicht und dann
könnt ihr es schön mit so einer
burgerpresse glatt drücken oder auch mit
einem Glas
[Musik]
z.B ich habe hier noch so einen
Esslöffel davon aufgehoben für die
Dekoration später der Boden kommt in den
Kühlschrank und ich zeige euch die
Zutaten für die
Creme dafür verwende ich 300 g Himbeeren
das gefrorene ein Päckchen agerager 50 g
Wasser 100 g Quark 150 g Puderzucker
etwas Vanilleextrakt 600 g Schlagsahne
und sanpar zum steifschlagen das erste
was ich jetzt mache ist hier die
himbeären einzukochen da kommt agerager
mit dazu mit Wasser und das ganze wird
dann schön aufgekocht die Himbeeren die
schmelzen dann und dann muss es auch 2
Minuten lang sprudelnd kochen damit das
agerager auch wirklich wirken kann dann
fülle ich das kurz um und während das
hier lauwarm abkühlt gerne immer mal
wieder umrühren aber nicht zu kalt
werden lassen es wird dann schon ab
einem gewissen Punkt ganz schön schnell
fest und dann kann ich jetzt hier in der
Zwischenzeit schon mal Quark mit
Puderzucker und Vanilleextrakt cremig
[Musik]
rühren mus noch kurz ein bisschen
abkühlen ich fül es mal da
rein und dann gebe ich von der
Quarkmasse ein paar Esslöffel hier dazu
rühr das erstmal ein und dann kommt hier
zurück zur großen Quarkmasse damit das
Ganze durch das akerager eben nicht so
Gele Klümpchen
bekommt deswegen erstmal so mit der
Temperatur
[Musik]
angleichen
einrühren und dann könnt das jetzt hier
[Musik]
reinfüllen mein Papa ist
da mein Papa ist der
شش
[Musik]
ما
und dann gebe ich jetzt hier die Sahne
dazu und schlag die Creme mit
[Musik]
sanpsteif jetzt kommt die Torte in den
Kühlschrank und entweder für 4er Stunden
oder über Nacht ich werde es jetzt noch
abdecken mit einem tortenretter und W
sie morgen fertig dekorieren und dann
habt ihr sie einfach bereit und könnt
sie dann zum Valentinstag servieren wir
werden sie aber noch schön dekorieren
während die Torte gerade noch kühlt kann
ich schon mal Dekoration herstellen und
zwar möchte ich mit meinen
Silikonförmchen hier diese kleinen
herzdiamanten diamantherzen herstellen
und dafür nehme ich jetzt weiße
kuveratüre geb sie über ein warmes aber
nicht mehr kochendes Wasserbad und
schmelzt zwei Drittel davon jetzt nehme
ich das ganze vom Wasserbad runter und
geb ein Drittel Kuvertüre noch dazu und
dann habt ihr nämlich die perfekte
weiterverarbeitungstemperatur und die
Kuvertüre hat einen wunderschönen Glanz
eigentlich muss man sie jetzt noch
prüfen machen wir natürlich so wie sich
es gehört so wie sich es gehört immer
kuouvertüre prüfen ob sie schön fest
wird hier mit der teigarte rein hier
ablegen und dann müsste sie innerhalb
von einer Minute ungefr fest werden
einen schönen Glanz bekommen ich
riskiere es jetzt einfach es wird schon
passen ich fülle das jetzt hier in der
Dosierflasche dann kann ich ein bisschen
einfacher arbeiten und dann schön hier
reinfüllen
und jetzt einfach auf dem tortenretter
und
klopfen dann verteilt sich die Kuvertüre
und die Luft
entweicht und ab mit euch in den
Kühlschrank oder auf die Terrasse da ist
es auch noch kalt die Torte ist jetzt
super gekühlt über Nacht jetzt kann ich
sie auf eine Tortenplatte schon mal
setzen dann die Folie
wegziehen ich roll die immer drunter
weg und jetzt die Herzform lösen
[Musik]
ah so eine schöne
Torte da muss man nicht mal mehr den
Rand schön machen der ist wunderschön
die dekoriere ich jetzt weiter ich habe
jetzt hier schon mal die herzpralinen
sozusagen ausgelöst ich habe noch
frische himben ich habe noch bisschen
von dem Bröselboden ich habe gefrier
getrocknete Himbeeren machen wir das
jetzt mal schön
hier
[Musik]
ich finde da sieht man immer ganz gut
wie schnell man aus so einer einfachen
morte so eine richtig geniale Torte
machen kann gefreh getrocknete Früchte
sind für mich immer so das non plus
ultra da kriegt man einen tollen Effekt
und gerade auf so einer Platte finde ich
muss man immer so das Gesamtkunstwerk
betrachten deswegen dekorere ich immer
so bisschen auch die Platte mit dann ist
das immer richtig schön und das wird mir
jetzt so schon reichen aber als Valentin
ist packe ich da die Herzchen mit drauf
aber ich ma kurz meine Fingerchen
[Musik]
sauber wow die sieht so richtig lecker
aus okay tol möchtest du die
valentinstagsorte probieren
natürlich oh mein Gott sieht so smooth
aus so eine richtige morte geworden
himbermous happy Valentine's Day oh dir
auch euch allen auch Valentinstag ist
immer so schön Zeit mit mit den Liebsten
ja mit den Kindern ja aber muss auch zu
sich selbst gut sein ich muss jetzt
unbedingt probieren ja kom
probieren m oh mein
Gott oh mein Gott wow die schmeckt
wie
fruchting Zwerge Fruchtzwerge fr oh mein
Gott oh mein Gott die ist richtig gut
die ist so
locker oh mein Gott ich muss gleich mein
Papa noch ein Stück bringen das Rezept
gibt's wie immer zum Nachlesen auf
sellisminusblock.de oder in meiner App
probiert es unbedingt aus ist wirklich
richtig erfrisch und richtig lecker und
die Kühlzeit über Nacht war
perfekt super also richtig smooth smooth
like
[Gelächter]
Butter bis zum nächsten Mal tschüss GU
mal so ein Herz dann schließt sich das
am Ende so in so einem Herzchen okay
so okay es war echt
kitschig woll drunter verschwinden das
ging
nicht